- Naïma Moutchou:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La parole est à madame
Isabelle Santiago
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Isabelle Santiago:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
Samedi dernier,
trois enfants ont été assassinés
par leur père
à Alfortville,
dans ma circonscription.
Je tiens
à leur rendre hommage
en ce jour et à exprimer
tout mon soutien
à leur mère.
Nous sommes face
à une réalité tragique.
Depuis le début de l'année,
nous recensons 44 infanticides
en France.
Ce constat est accablant.
Il nous glace
d'effroi et brise
nos coeurs.
N'oublions pas que la violence
faite
à ces enfants
dans le cadre familial
est très souvent corrélée
aux violences conjugales.
Quelques jours après la Journée
internationale
de lutte
contre la violence faite
aux femmes, je tiens
à rendre hommage
aux 121 victimes
de féminicide
depuis le début
de l'année, qui laissent
derrière elles 108 enfants.
Combien de temps
cela va-t-il durer?
La France ne peut
accepter cette situation
et doit trouver le moyen
de mieux protéger
ces femmes et leurs enfants.
Plus que jamais,
nous devons encourager
les victimes à parler
et plus que jamais,
nous devons mettre
l'accent sur le repérage
des négligences et des violences.
Il faut revoir
les protocoles de prise
en charge des victimes.
Vous avez annoncé lors du comité
interministériel
pour l'enfance
le développement d'une aide
par juridiction à l'horizon 2027.
Mais le temps
de l'enfant
n'est pas celui
de l'adulte
ni celui de la justice.
Cette généralisation
doit aller beaucoup
plus vite et être accompagnée
de véritables moyens.
Ces unités sont essentielles
car composées
de professionnels
clés, tels
que des pédiatres,
des médecins légistes,
des pédopsychiatres,
des puéricultrices
et des travailleurs sociaux.
Les mineurs
sont particulièrement
vulnérables et il est temps
de coordonner
une véritable médecine
médico-légale
qui va de pair
avec la détection
des négligences.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran, porte-parole
du gouvernement.
- Olivier Véran: Merci beaucoup.
Madame la députée,
le drame familial
que vous avez évoqué
nous a tous bouleversés.
J'ai une pensée
pour la maman
de ces enfants,
qui vit ce qu'aucun parent
ne devrait jamais vivre.
Je tiens à rappeler
ce que le gouvernement
a mis en place dans la lutte
contre les violences faites
aux enfants, qui sont bien
trop nombreuses.
Le précédent plan
pour la période 2020-2022
a permis de renforcer
la prévention
des violences
sexuelles à l'école,
avec un dépistage
systématique à l'occasion
des visites médicales
obligatoires.
Nous agissons
contre les violences
avec la mise en place de nouveaux
centres spécialisés
dans la prise en charge
de psycho-trauma
des enfants victimes de violences.
Il y a désormais
15 de ces centres.
Nous avons déployé 145 unités
d'accueil pédiatrique enfants
en danger.
Le déploiement de ces unités
propose d'accueillir
un enfant victime
pour qu'il ait
un accompagnement médical,
social, juridique.
On avait prévu une unité
par département
et il est désormais
programmé une unité
par ressort de tribunal
judiciaire.
Cela nécessite
le temps de la mise
en place.
Nous allons
plus vite, croyez
en nos engagements.
Je salue les travaux
que vous avez réalisés,
notamment cette proposition
parlementaire
que le gouvernement a soutenue.
Cette proposition
de loi doit cheminer
au Sénat et nous souhaitons
que l'examen aille
le plus vite possible.
Nous souhaitons
que les conditions soient réunies
pour que les principales
propositions
que vous faites,
qui rejoignent
les propositions
de la Ciivise, puissent
être appliqués pleinement
de manière opérationnelle.
Nous sommes dans
une course
contre la montre,
mais là-dessus,
l'unité nationale fera loi et sera
source d'efficacité.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Didier Parakian.
- David Parakian:
Ma question s'adresse
à la secrétaire
d'Etat chargée
de la Ville.
Si je vous dis "à jamais
les premiers",
vous me répondez
évidemment "Marseille".
Vous étiez vendredi
dernier
dans la Cité phocéenne
pour annoncer l'accélération
du plan Marseille en grand.
C'est la preuve
que ne sont pas
que des mots,
ce sont surtout des actes
pour les Marseillais
et les Marseillais.
C'est un plan
ambitieux et unique
qui a été lancé
en septembre 2021
pour faire de Marseille
un laboratoire
en France des nouvelles
politiques publiques
autour de la sécurité,
du logement,
du social et de la culture.
Ce plan, c'est 5
milliards d'euros
de l'Etat qui vont générer
15 milliards
de redressement au total.
C'est aussi 20 ans du budget
d'investissement
de la ville de Marseille.
C'est une chance
historique
pour notre ville,
avec des projets
qui vont contribuer
à améliorer la vie
de ses habitants.
Madame la ministre,
vous avez insisté
sur la nécessité
de jouer collectif
pour réussir.
Soit tout le monde
gagne,
soit tout le monde perd.
Je partage vos mots
du fond du coeur.
Cette volonté de travailler
à l'unisson doit mobiliser
toutes les énergies
pour Marseille
et ses habitants.
Madame la ministre,
pouvez-vous
nous détailler ce plan?
Quels seront les moyens
de cette nouvelle étape
pour faire de la deuxième
ville de France
la capitale de la Méditerranée?
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sabrina Agresti-Roubache,
secrétaire d'Etat chargée
de la Citoyenneté
et de la ville.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
si vous le permettez,
j'associe tous
les députés de Marseille
à votre question.
Le président
de la République,
lors de son discours fondateur
de septembre 2021,
était venu annoncer
non seulement
qu'il se mettait
au chevet de Marseille,
mais que l'Etat
entretenait un vrai plan
de sauvetage
pour cette ville
qui a accumulé
des retards considérables
dans tous les sujets.
Je reprends juste
rapidement pour répondre
à votre question.
Je suis venue vendredi
dernier annoncer
un plan d'accélération
de Marseille
en grand.
Vous disiez que c'est un plan de 5
milliards d'investissements.
C'est un milliard
pour les écoles,
dont 188 qui seront
totalement rénovées
dans toute la ville.
C'est un plan
de désenclavement
de toute la ville.
Il y a aussi un milliard
pour les transports,
dont 500 millions
en investissements.
C'est 350 millions
d'euros que le ministre
de la Justice
est venu annoncer
pour une nouvelle cité judiciaire.
C'est aussi, et j'y tiens,
650 millions d'euros
sur un nouveau projet.
Je finis par le logement,
je suis venu annoncer
des opérations d'intérêt national.
Cela va prendre
forme dès janvier
avec un établissement
public d'aménagement
où l'on va créer
une filiale pour expliquer
qu'on est capable
de construire
plus à Marseille
pour les Marseillais,
qui vivent dans des conditions
difficiles.
On ne peut plus accepter
que les écoles soient aussi
délabrées,
qu'on continue à vivre
dans des quartiers aussi délabrés.
On sait que ce plan est un plan
de sauvetage inédit initié
par le président de la République.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Hendrik Davi
pour la France Insoumise.
- Hendrik Davi:
Monsieur le ministre,
la planète brûle,
littéralement,
avec un réchauffement qui pourrait
atteindre 3 degrés
en 2100
selon les scientifiques,
très loin des objectifs
de l'accord
de Paris.
La COP28 s'ouvre demain à Dubaï.
Nous sommes de plus
en plus victimes
des conséquences
de ce changement climatique.
Canicule, sécheresse,
incendies, tempêtes
et inondations...
En 2017,
Emmanuel Macron inventait
le slogan
"Make Our Planet Great Again".
Il y a les paroles
et il y a les actes.
Vous prolongez l'usage
du glyphosate,
vous renoncez à rénover
les logements,
vous signez un nouvel
accord d'échange
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande,
vous favorisez
la route avec la A69.
Lundi, j'ai visité
avec d'autres parlementaires
le centre de Fos-sur-Mer.
La Commission européenne exige
que Fret SNCF rembourse plusieurs
millions d'euros car elle aurait
été subventionnée
par la SNCF au détriment
de ses concurrents.
A la clé, la session
pendant 10 ans
de 30% d'activité,
un record du fret
sur la route
et la suppression de près
de 500 postes.
Cette solution
fragilise l'entreprise
et suscite
beaucoup de colère
chez les salariés.
Favoriser
le transport routier
est une hérésie
pour le climat,
la santé et la sécurité routière.
Comme disait un syndicaliste
rencontré lundi,
pendant 10 ans,
on va regarder les camions rouler
et voir nos enfants
crever car la SNCF
ne pourra pas reprendre
un seul marché.
Il faut désobéir
à la Commission européenne,
et engager un plan de soutien
au fret ferroviaire.
Quand allez-vous sortir
de l'inaction climatique
pour laquelle vous avez déjà
été condamné?
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu,
ministre de la Transition
écologique.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
passer de la parole
aux actes,
c'est ce que nous faisons
depuis 2017.
La condamnation pour inaction
climatique vise
les émissions entre 2015 et 2018.
Vous utilisez l'écologie
comme un prétexte
pour votre lutte des classes.
Passer de la parole aux actes?
Depuis 2018, Etat
met plus d'argent
dans le ferroviaire
que dans les routes.
Quand la gauche
était aux responsabilités,
on mettait plus d'argent
dans les routes
que dans le ferroviaire.
Regardez la réalité.
Vous m'interrogez
sur le démantèlement
du fret SNCF,
vous aviez décidé de faire
une petite introduction.
Clément Beaune
l'a redit, il n'y aura
aucun démantèlement de fret SNCF.
Le gouvernement se bat
dans un scénario négocié
avec l'Union Européenne.
S'il ne se passe rien,
c'est 5 milliards d'euros
à rembourser
et c'est le dépôt de bilan.
Vous proposez de désobéir.
Pourquoi personne n'y a pensé?
C'est génial, comme slogan.
C'est tellement facile.
C'est de la pensée magique.
Le choix
que nous faisons
est celui de soutenir
comme jamais
nos opérateurs ferroviaires.
295 millions en 2022.
C'est un record.
4 milliards d'euros investis
d'ici 2032 uniquement
sur le fret ferroviaire.
Et enfin,
nous augmentons de 50%
les crédits liés
à la régénération
de nos 29.000
kilomètres de voies
dans le cadre du conseil
d'orientation
des infrastructures.
Vous pouvez tenir
vos propos de tribune,
continuer à faire
en sorte que rien
ne se passe, mais personne
ne vous croit.
Votre petit manège
ne remplace pas l'incurie
de ce que vous proposez.
Il y a ceux qui agissent
et ceux qui parlent.
Changez de catégorie.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Julien bayou
pour le groupe écologiste.
- Julien Bayou: Merci.
Avant de démarrer
cette question,
permettez-moi
d'avoir une pensée
pour une grande
militante de l'écologie
qui nous a quittés ce matin.
On pense très fort
à elle et à sa famille.
Madame la présidente,
ma question s'adresse
au ministre de l'Ecologie.
Demain s'ouvre la COP28.
On pourrait estimer
que c'est une mauvaise
plaisanterie,
une conférence
sur le climat
chez un pétrolier,
mais nous avons besoin
de ce type
de cadre de négociations.
Pour que cette COP
soit réussie,
il faut de grandes ambitions.
Il faut annoncer la fin
des énergies fossiles
et un plan d'action
pour l'adaptation.
Comment voulez-vous
que la France
soit crédible quand,
sur ces deux sujets,
elle est en retard?
Sur la fin
des énergies fossiles,
vous avez prolongé
les centrales à charbon.
Vous avez fait
un pont d'or à Total
sur un nouveau port méthanier.
La France se rue
sur le gaz d'Azerbaïdjan
en soutenant
l'effort de guerre
contre l'Arménie.
Le président Macron
soutient personnellement
le projet de Total
en Ouganda
et en Tanzanie.
Vous avez parlé d'une
France à 4 degrés.
Je ne sais pas si on mesure
ce que cela signifie
en termes d'inondation,
de rendement agricole
en déclin et peut-être
d'assureurs
qui vont nous lâcher.
Pour les inondations,
vous aurez
les gens
à assurer
et ceux qui ont tout perdu.
Où en êtes-vous
de ce plan d'action?
Pouvez-vous nous affirmer
que la France
va porter ces deux grandes
ambitions
à partir de demain à la COP28?
Comment la France
peut-elle être crédible
si elle ne met pas en cohésion
ses grands discours internationaux
et ses actes au niveau national?
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu,
ministre de la Transition
écologique.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
je veux saluer
la tonalité de vos propos
sur le fait
que nous avons besoin
d'un succès à la COP28.
Même si le lieu
où c'est organisé
nous invite
à être pessimiste,
comment ne pas aller discuter?
Sur l'exemplarité,
nous savons
à quel point
notre pays
n'est pas dans le bon rythme.
Mais quand on se compare
et que l'on perçoit
qu'il n'y a qu'un
écart des pays
qui ont commencé
à baisser les émissions,
nous faisons partie de ceux-là.
Nous amplifions ces baisses.
C'était 1 % entre 2012 et 2017.
C'est 2 % depuis 2017
et plus de 4 %
sur ce deuxième semestre.
C'est le rythme
que nous devons tenir
pour être au rendez-vous
de nos engagements climatiques.
C'est le cas
pour cette année 2023.
L'adaptation est l'autre
grand chantier.
Aucun ministre
de l'Ecologie avant moi n'avait
mis les pieds
dans le plat en disant
qu'il fallait
qu'on se prépare
à ce que la somme
des engagements internationaux
ne permet pas de tenir
l'engagement
des accords de Paris.
Je l'ai dit le 30 janvier.
J'ai annoncé qu'il faudrait un an.
L'an prochain, nous allons
présenter l'adaptation
et en particulier un volet
sur les assurances.
La multiplicité
des sécheresses,
des inondations,
ont conduit
à ce qu'on ait un volume
de catastrophes
qui ne cesse d'augmenter.
Chaque 10e de degré compte.
1,5 degré, c'est le consensus
scientifique
pour éviter l'effondrement.
Mais si on est à 2,8,
ce n'est pas
les mêmes conséquences.
Nous sommes en train
d'avancer
sur des référentiels
techniques,
nous repensons le dispositif
des catastrophes
et des assurances,
et nous repensons
notre gestion
des vagues de chaleur.
C'est un travail
que nous soumettrons
à la concertation.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Mohamed Laqhila
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Mohamed Laqhila: Merci.
J'associe à cette question
ma collègue.
En 2018, une loi instaurait
des avancées majeures telles
que le droit à l'erreur
et la simplification
des démarches a ouvert
une nouvelle ère
dans les relations
avec l'administration.
Mais un long chemin
reste à parcourir
pour simplifier la vie
de nos entreprises,
d'autant que certains
allégements
sont aussi annulés
par de nouvelles contraintes.
La récente
consultation
que vous avez initiée
témoigne
de votre compréhension
et de l'importance
de ces défis actuels.
Aujourd'hui,
la jurisprudence récente
de la Cour de cassation
vient percuter
la vie des entreprises
en permettant l'accumulation
des congés payés
pendant les arrêts maladie.
Cela soulève
une inquiétude
chez les dirigeants de nos PME.
Bien qu'alignés
sur la législation européenne,
elle soulève de profondes
interrogations quant
à sa pertinence,
surtout dans le contexte
économique actuel.
Imaginez le fardeau pour nos PME,
déjà fragilisées.
Les conséquences peuvent
être désastreuses
sur leur trésorerie,
surtout pour les plus fragiles
d'entre elles.
Monsieur le ministre,
face à ce défi,
quelle est la stratégie
du gouvernement,
à la fois pour simplifier
drastiquement
les charges administratives,
et également
pour alléger
le fardeau financier
de nos employeurs
tout en préservant
le droit des salariés?
C'est l'équilibre
de notre économie
et la survie
de nos entreprises
qui sont en jeu.
Nos entreprises comptent sur vous.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrot,
ministre délégué
chargé du Numérique.
- Jean-Noël Barrot:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
le gouvernement partage
votre obsession
de la simplification,
un sujet sur lequel
vous avez, aux côtés
du gouvernement,
au sein de la majorité,
agit depuis bientôt sept ans.
Avec la loi qui a permis
de simplifier
la démarche
des entrepreneurs,
la loi ESSOC,
qui a permis à la France
pour quatre années
consécutives
d'être le pays
le plus attractif
pour les investissements
étrangers d'Europe,
la loi dédiée aux indépendants
qui simplifient
un certain nombre
d'accès aux droits
qui sont les leurs,
et je citerai également
le projet de loi
industrie verte
qui simplifie
les démarches permettant
à nos entreprises de faire
leur transition verte.
Le travail doit continuer.
Notre ambition ne s'arrête pas là.
Bruno Le Maire
et Olivia Grégoire
ont souhaité lancer
les rencontres
de la simplification.
Je veux citer
la contribution décisive
de nos collaborateurs
et collaboratrices.
Des rencontres
ont eu lieu
dans une dizaine
de départements
et vont se poursuivre.
Elles vont conduire
à ce qu'un texte
en soit issu, consacré
à la simplification
de la vie
de nos TPE et PME,
qui va permettre
de vous satisfaire.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Benjamin Saint-Huile
pour le groupe Liberté,
indépendant outre-mer
et territoire.
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Bruno
Le Maire.
Les partenaires
sociaux ont trouvé
un accord sur la nouvelle
convention assurance-chômage
Unedic, accord
qui n'a pas été agréé
par le gouvernement,
considérant
que le compte n'y était pas.
Le gouvernement a donné
six mois supplémentaires
aux partenaires
sociaux pour trouver
un atterrissage.
Bruno Le Maire,
à grand renfort de communication,
nous a dit
à plusieurs reprises
qu'il souhaitait voir réduire
la durée d'indemnisation
des chômeurs seniors,
pour la ramener
de 27 à 18 mois.
Cette annonce
nous choque
parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'autres mesures
que celle de la punition
collective
qui nous serait alors infligée.
Ma question
est relativement simple.
Cette position est-elle
la position officielle
du gouvernement
en tant que telle ou,
au contraire, est-ce
une provocation
pour essayer d'obliger
une négociation
sous contrat
des organisations patronales
et syndicales?
Est-ce un écran
de fumée pour essayer
de faire oublier
que derrière le grand discours
de la fable du plein
emploi, les chiffres
du chômage sont élevés?
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean,
ministre déléguée chargée
de l'Enseignement.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
je vais rappeler
le contexte.
Les partenaires
sociaux ont négocié
un accord
sur l'assurance-chômage
qu'ils ont signé le 10
novembre dernier.
Cet accord confirme
les différentes réformes
qui ont été conduites
sur l'assurance-chômage
depuis 2019.
Grâce au plein emploi,
nous faisons reculer
la précarité et nous protégeons
concrètement
les Français.
Cela veut dire
que cet accord signé
par les partenaires
sociaux, s'il pose
un certain nombre
de principes, il doit aussi
être complété
par d'autres dispositions
pour favoriser
l'emploi des seniors.
Il renvoie à la définition
des règles
à la négociation
sur le nouveau pacte
de la vie au travail qui doit
bientôt s'ouvrir.
Le gouvernement prend
à bras-le-corps
la question de l'emploi
des seniors.
Ils ne peuvent
plus être une variable
d'ajustement
de notre marché du travail.
Nous sommes conscients
des fragilités
de notre système
d'assurance-chômage
et de l'impact
sur l'emploi des seniors,
qui sont parfois
laissés sur le banc
de touche
plusieurs
années avant de pouvoir
liquider
leur retraite.
C'est un gâchis de compétences
et d'expérience
pour notre économie.
Le gouvernement sait
que ce sont souvent
des périodes complexes,
douloureuses
pour ces actifs,
qui ont encore
tant de choses
à apporter à la société
du travail.
Nous sommes convaincus
que notre système doit mieux
prendre en compte le report
de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits.
C'était un des objets
de la réforme
des retraites
que nous avons votée.
Ces négociations doivent
être poursuivies
par les partenaires sociaux.
La négociation sur l'emploi
des seniors commence
tout juste.
C'est un moment important
qui doit aboutir
à des solutions concrètes.
Il est important
que chacun y prenne
sa part.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je vous remercie.
Monsieur le député?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile:
A une question simple,
vous faites une réponse
longue, tortueuse,
avec des mots
choisis pour noyer
le poisson.
J'espère
que vos conseillers
dans la voiture
vous diront que c'était
une belle réponse.
Dans la réforme
des retraites, il n'y
avait rien sur l'emploi
des seniors,
et les quelques petites
mesures
ont été balayées
par les conséquences
tensionnelles.
Vous demandez
toujours aux mêmes
des efforts.
Vous avez réformé
l'assurance-chômage
pour réduire la durée
d'indemnisation
des chômeurs.
On ne demande
jamais aucun effort
aux entreprises,
jamais une hypothèse
de coercition.
Vous faites toujours peser
sur les mêmes l'effort.
Quand on est senior,
on a plus de mal
à trouver un emploi!
- Naïma Moutchou: merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Victor Habert-Dassault
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Victor Habert-Dassault: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Les agriculteurs de l'Oise
et d'autres départements
de France continuent
de renverser
les panneaux de sortie
et d'entrée d'agglomération
de plusieurs
communes pour tenter
de rendre visible
leur colère, à défaut
de se sentir entendus.
Quatre boulons
à dévisser et le tour
est joué.
Pas de déchets déversés
devant les préfectures.
Ce geste simple
dissimule un mal
plus profond et plus pernicieux.
Cette action n'a
qu'un seul message:
les agriculteurs
souhaitent vivre
de leur métier.
Cette signalisation
dissonante se retrouve
au coeur de nos politiques
agricoles.
Il faut consommer
français
alors que 70%
de nos fruits et 40%
de nos légumes sont importés.
Si on prend l'exemple
sur l'élevage bovin,
la France représente
un des modèles
les plus vertueux
en matière d'élevage
mais doit faire face à des modèles
ultra industrialisés,
avec 25% d'éleveurs français
de moins en 10 ans
comme conséquence.
Nos agriculteurs subissent
une concurrence déloyale.
Il faut imposer le respect
des normes appliquées
aux produits issues
de l'Union Européenne
dans le cadre
des accords commerciaux.
Je pense aux négociations
avec l'Australie.
Notre souveraineté
alimentaire
est en danger.
L'exemple du maïs est édifiant.
La production française
était autosuffisante
il y a quelques années
et nous sommes tristement devenus
le plus gros
importateur de maïs
de l'Union avec des traitements
utilisés interdits
en Europe.
C'est un enfer normatif
et démocratique
qui rend leur travail
précaire,
malgré leur passion,
leurs compétences
et le soin extrême
qu'ils y consacrent.
C'est un avertissement
que les agriculteurs
nous envoient afin
que notre souveraineté alimentaire
persiste.
Les graines de leur révolte
porteront-elles
les fruits de leurs actions?
- Naïma Moutchou:
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Véran,
ministre délégué chargé
du Renouveau démocratique.
- Olivier Véran: Merci.
Monsieur
le député, merci
pour votre question.
Vous avez raison,
on doit mener
cette bataille
pour la souveraineté alimentaire
française.
On doit pour cela aimer
nos agriculteurs,
porter notre agriculture
et tout faire
pour accompagner
l'agriculture française
dans un environnement
mondialisé difficile,
normatif, face
au dérèglement climatique
qui ajoute parfois
de la misère
et de la détresse
aux difficultés
du quotidien.
Monsieur le député,
on agit
pour les agriculteurs français.
Il y a eu la loi
EGalim qui a permis
de protéger les revenus
des agriculteurs
depuis 2017.
Vous n'êtes pas obligé
de crier, monsieur
le député.
Je vous répond
à la place du ministre
de l'Agriculture,
on peut peut-être s'écouter.
Je vous rappelle
la PAQ qui permet
d'avoir des avances
de versements d'agriculteurs
avec 4,5 milliards d'euros.
Vous avez parlé
du normatif,
mais c'est un chemin
difficile sur lequel
la France avance.
Des décisions ont été prises
au niveau européen
pour protéger
nos producteurs
de la concurrence
qui ne respecte
pas forcément
les normes
que nous nous appliquons.
La culture est aussi
confrontée
à de nouveaux défis:
le gel, la grêle,
la sécheresse.
Le gouvernement
était d'ailleurs
aux côtés
des agriculteurs touchés
par la tempête
en Bretagne et suite
aux inondations.
Un fond de soutien de 80
millions d'euros
a été déclenché.
Cela a été le cas
pour les épisodes sanitaires,
je pense au fait
d'avoir été le premier pays
au monde à pouvoir
déployer une vaccination
à large échelle
sur la grippe aviaire.
Le gouvernement
est mobilisé
pour le défi des transitions.
800 millions
d'euros mobilisés
dans le budget
2024 pour épauler
les démarches de planification
écologique, bref,
nous faisons face aux défis.
Nous sommes tous du côté
de nos agriculteurs.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Anne-Cécile Violland,
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Anne-Cécile Violland: Merci.
Chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
des Solidarités
et des Familles de France,
Aurore Bergé.
Lors de la conférence nationale
du handicap fin avril,
le président de la République
s'est engagé
à déployer pour les enfants
et les adultes
en situation de handicap 50.000
nouvelles solutions d'ici 2030.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes quelques députés
à être sollicités
par nos dispositifs locaux,
qui souhaitent
être acteurs de la mise
en oeuvre de ces 50.000
nouvelles solutions,
et notamment les 100 instituts
médico-éducatifs
dans les écoles.
Mais ces femmes
et ces hommes engagés
au quotidien dans les différentes
structures médico-sociales,
bien souvent associatives,
sont confrontés
à une absence
de document-cadre,
de feuille de route
pour la mise
en oeuvre de ces solutions.
Je connais l'engagement
des bénévoles
comme des salariés
du médico-social,
qui se sentent
bien souvent
moins bien considérés
que les acteurs
du sanitaire.
Je veux saluer la résilience.
On recense aujourd'hui
50.000 postes vacants
dans ce secteur,
d'où la nécessité
de revaloriser
l'attractivité
de ces profils.
Mais nos acteurs
locaux souhaitent
se saisir de cette opportunité
et participer
à la création
de ces nouvelles solutions.
Madame la ministre,
permettez-nous
de répondre à nos interlocuteurs.
Où en est-on
sur le déploiement
de ce plan?
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé, ministre
des Solidarités et des Familles.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Vous avez parlé
d'attractivité des métiers
et vous avez raison.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle,
quand le ministre
de la Santé a annoncé
la revalorisation
pour les nuits
et les week-ends
dans le secteur sanitaire,
que nous avons fait
la même chose
dans le secteur médical.
C'est le cas
pour ceux qui travaillent
dans les établissements
auprès de personnes
en situation de handicap.
Il n'y aura
plus jamais d'oubliés
du Ségur.
Il n'y a pas d'un côté,
le sanitaire,
et de l'autre, le médico-social.
Les deux travaillent ensemble.
Ensuite, il y a les 50.000
nouvelles solutions,
et des solutions au pluriel.
Les personnes en situation
de handicap attendent
une pluralité
de solutions qui doivent
se déployer.
Pendant très longtemps,
dans notre pays,
on n'avait pas envie
de voir la question
du handicap.
Géographiquement,
on voit que ces établissements
ont été installés en périphérie.
Demain, 100 nouveaux instituts
médico-éducatifs seront
au coeur de nos établissements
scolaires
et ils seront
construits avant la fin 2027.
C'est la capacité
à avoir des solutions
pour les enfants
qui ne pourraient
pas être dans l'école
ordinaire,
dans une classe
mais qui doivent pouvoir passer
la même porte d'entrée
que tous les autres
enfants, celle
de l'école, afin
d'avoir accès
à la scolarisation.
Le cahier des charges
sera fini
dès le début de l'année.
Il sera transmis à l'ensemble
des professionnels.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Timothée Houssin
pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Timothée Houssin:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie
et concerne l'avenir des salariés
d'une verrerie centenaire.
J'ai une pensée
pour les 208 salariés
qui viennent
de perdre leur emploi
et pour leur famille.
L'an dernier,
la hausse de 250%
de sa facture énergétique liée
aux mauvais choix
de ce gouvernement
est venue achever
cette entreprise,
entraînant son placement
en redressant judiciaire.
Il y a six mois,
je vous alertais
sur les risques de fermeture
et Olivia Grégoire
a assuré que nous aurions
un tableau
plus noir.
Cela n'a pas suffi,
malgré la mobilisation
des élus locaux.
Cette fermeture
est une nouvelle perte
de compétitivité
pour la France,
alors que le pays
a enregistré en 2022
le pire déficit commercial
de son histoire.
C'est un cataclysme
à l'échelle locale.
Sans cette entreprise,
il n'y
a plus de raison
de rester,
selon un salarié.
Les retombées économiques
de cette industrie
pour les commerces
du territoire
sont indispensables.
Tout doit être mis
en oeuvre pour offrir
une nouvelle activité
de production
au tissu local.
En février, Bruno Le Maire
déclarait qu'aucun salarié
ne serait laissé
sans solution d'emploi.
Quelles mesures
concrètes prévoyez-vous
pour accompagner
le reclassement
de ces 208 salariés?
A l'heure où les politiques
européennes
sont responsables
de ce désastre,
prévoyez-vous
au nom de la France
de demander la mobilisation
du fonds européen d'ajustement
à la mondialisation en faveur
des travailleurs,
qui peut
être mobilisé
dès lors que plus de 200 personnes
perdent
leur emploi en raison
de mutations économiques?
- Naïma Moutchou:
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Noël
Barrot.
- Jean-Noël Barrot:
Monsieur le député,
j'excuse l'absence
de Roland Lescure,
ministre chargé de l'Industrie.
La décision du tribunal
de commerce
de prononcer
la liquidation
de cette entreprise
est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour le territoire
et pour les 200 collaborateurs
de cette entreprise
de verrerie, installée
depuis bien longtemps
dans votre département.
Le ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances
a échangé
sur la situation
depuis que le tribunal
de commerce
a rendu sa décision
avec le maire
de la commune,
dont il me charge
de saluer auprès
de vous l'engagement total
sur ce dossier.
Bruno Le Maire
s'est engagé
depuis le début
des difficultés rencontrées
par l'entreprise,
mais cela
n'aura pas suffi
tant cette technologie centenaire
ne suffit plus tout à fait
pour redresser
les marchés
que cette entreprise
avait l'habitude de servir.
Ce qu'Olivia Grégoire
avait dit à l'époque
est toujours vrai.
Le ministère sera
toujours aux côtés
des collaborateurs de l'entreprise
afin qu'une solution
soit trouvée pour chacun.
Sur les remarques
plus générales
que vous avez faites,
je ne peux
pas vous laisser
dire que la France
et le gouvernement
ne s'inquiètent
pas de l'avenir
industriel
de notre pays,
après tout ce que nous avons fait
pour mettre fin
à deux décennies d'hémorragie
des usines et de l'emploi
industriel
dans notre pays.
C'est grâce à cette
majorité
que l'on ouvre
des entreprises en France
et que les emplois
industriels seront créés
dans un pays
qui n'en comptait plus.
C'est à cette majorité
que nous le devons.
- Naïma Moutchou:
Monsieur le député?
- Timothée Houssin:
Nous attendions
des réponses
concrètes
mais nous n'en aurons aucune.
- Naïma Moutchou:
La parole est à madame
Mereana Reid Arbelot
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Mereana Reid Arbelot:
Monsieur
le ministre,
mes chers collègues,
alors qu'on dénonce
la paupérisation
des retraités
ultramarins, la réponse
du gouvernement
est de s'attaquer
au pouvoir d'achat
des actifs
en leur proposant
un dispositif
par capitalisation sur 100%
de la part majorée
de leur traitement indiciaire.
Tout fonctionnaire
actif a des retenues
sur le traitement
à l'indice hiérarchique.
Suite à un article de la loi
de finances rectificatives,
les retenues
sont faites aussi
sur la part majorée
du traitement indiciaire
des fonctionnaires
ultramarins du Pacifique.
Leur pension civile
n'est calculée
que sur le traitement
indiciaire
de base, sans sa part majorée.
L'indemnité temporaire de retraite
venait pourtant compenser
ce manque.
En 2008, le gouvernement
en place, suite
à un effet d'aubaine,
alors qu'il n'avait jamais exercé
en outre-mer,
a programmé l'extension
de cette indemnité sur 20 ans.
Nous sommes face
à un dilemme, un choix
de capitalisation exclusif
dont la suspension temporaire
est impossible pour passer
un moment difficile.
Le fonctionnaire
du Pacifique
a quelques mois
pour se décider
pour toute sa carrière.
Les 11.500 fonctionnaires
du Pacifique
ont des retenues
pensions civiles
sur la totalité
de leur traitement indiciaire
de base et sa part majorée.
Pourquoi
cette mesure
ne se base-t-elle pas
sur la totalité
de leurs revenus indiciaires?
- Naïma Moutchou:
La parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Madame la députée,
vous interrogez
le gouvernement
sur les conséquences
de l'extinction progressive
de l'indemnité temporaire
de retraite.
Je profite de votre question
pour saluer
au nom du gouvernement
l'engagement
des agents publics
en Polynésie
et dans l'ensemble
de nos territoires ultramarins.
Cette indemnité
permet à certains
de fonctionnaires
de prendre leur retraite
dans des territoires ultramarins.
Depuis 15 ans,
les gouvernements successifs
ont décidé de son extinction
progressive
et nous ne reviendrons pas
là-dessus.
Mais nous sommes conscients
des conséquences
de la fin
de cette indemnité
pour le pouvoir
d'achat des agents.
Le gouvernement de la République
a souhaité qu'un nouveau
dispositif soit mis en place,
en concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux.
Nous sommes partis
d'un constat simple:
si les écarts
entre le coût de la vie
dans l'Hexagone
et le Pacifique
sont pris en compte
pendant la vie active
de l'agent
grâce à une indexation
de la rémunération,
ces écarts
ne sont pas bien
pris en compte
lors des départs en retraite.
Monsieur le ministre
Stanislas Guerini
a ainsi proposé
un dispositif qui permet
à un agent
de la fonction publique
de l'Etat de surcotiser
au régime additionnel
de la fonction publique.
Cela aura un effet immédiat
et un montant plancher
est prévu.
Aucun agent
ne pourra toucher
moins de 4000 euros annuels.
Nous agissons concrètement
pour déployer
des mesures adaptées
aux retraités ultramarins
tout en maintenant
les principes d'équité
qui fondent notre système
de retraite.
- Naïma Moutchou: Merci.
La séance de questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.